hey reject nation its Greg Alva here
Jared Haven here Jared hi board is with
us today our board we just had an arm
there corrected me man Jared I met at
Collider he was a former contestant on
The Bachelorette I beat him haha days
I'm better than you
I still cry about it you should cry and
now I'm here and yep there's no there's
no end to this joke day for get out
sweet let's do it let's do it people she
wanted us to make it on this trailer for
here's your number two choice tags
there's nothing approved once again big
diversity equality and making but loads
of money aren't mutually exclusive that
was the most profitable film of the year
because because it was the windows and
it's gone screen doing a horror movie a
chance to shine by actually being inside
the horror movie not to go in a house
thank God for I'd does the alternate
ending it's super realistic I mean super
depressing
same difference enjoy deliciously cruel
casting that makes villains out of white
people's favorite white people turning
indie darlings West Wing alums and girls
girls into broad caricatures of
society's worst impressions of them and
if that makes you upset now you have
some inkling of how people feel when
they watch almost every other horror
movie seriously by people's main roles
and harm is to either die first or
comment on how often they die first
[Laughter]
details you didn't see the first time
like ROH stands up to the cars do so
they don't leave a paper
the only will drive black cars to
symbolize how they're also driving black
bodies and their victims are always
wearing hats or wigs to cover up the
scars from their surgery but then try to
ignore those details that don't add up
like brains ages fastest bodies so a
transplant wouldn't have that many years
no one ever notices all these guys went
missing after dating the same girl and
why does she live separate from the milk
it's not I think why people do is it is
it so gather round for a film that flips
your preconceived notion commentary the
progressives can be racist too the TSA
can be useful once in a while Tina's
relationship is a huge mistake because
you can't trust these white girls
Becky's are everywhere
starring Everybody Hates Chris oh the
lost Kardashian
ben Carson Kino Kino Kino stores of tea
sometimes your words is hit the white
wing Mumford side and an evocative
symbol of the marginalization of black
people in America I mean black hole son
the Stepford wife hey I'm just glad this
movie did well so I finally know whose
kids we feel I swear it's not a race
thing the show was just key and Peele
I never said which one was which
seriously I'm not a racist in fact I
would have voted for Obama a third time
if I wanna
[Laughter]
you know Godzilla and God s T on me very
cool very cool
open the how they doors PI you know I
really liked about this honest trailer
they were not afraid to actually go out
with their commentary talking about
black people and how they're portrayed
in movies and yeah talking about race
issues yeah yeah
not being afraid to actually make a
commentary on that so I thought was
really cool of them to actually do
because I could have played this safe
and just made fun of the movie alone
yeah they actually make a lot of
commentary on how black people are
portrayed in movies only and flipping
the stereotypes and whatnot I never
realized how the main guy Daniel Kalia
is ridiculously polite like when they're
saying like all the way people were
driving black cars to symbolize that the
driving right or the wigs and all that
and weaves and then she's like doesn't
want to leave a paper trail which is
yeah because I was in the movie one time
I've always said that I'm sure on a
repeat view and I'll get way more from
it totally and just watching the honest
trailer made me go wow there would be a
lot to get right now a good point about
how the brain trance the brain doesn't
really aged that much really wouldn't
make that big of a difference great on
his trip really funny stuff and what a
great point about how black people in
horror movies are always the first ones
to die or make commentary it's like a
cliche at this point it is a recluse
shame no this movie was amazing and I'm
so happy to see that I got all these
Oscar nom until it cuz I was sold that
this would get snubbed I thought like
maybe it'll get like possibly a director
one but to get Best Picture and Best
Actor I think after what happened at
last year's Oscars last year's there was
at two years ago was it two years ago no
mom I won last year oh that's right so
it's two years ago yeah where is the guy
well times know no black people were
nominated
there's a big boycott yeah maybe get out
Jared hey heaven Haven in the middle
name Matthew so simple
I know Jared Matthew Haven parents of
circle people you can follow them on
Twitter at a it's in the description
yeah it's all bottom of the screen here
subscribe to the real rejection do what
he said click the notification bow and
we'll catch you guys on the
flippety-flip